oggi
no non c'è un coniglio in questa
e non c'è
token a chi è che cosa vediamo
nell'immagine vediamo l'evoluzione della
specie
io come credo molti di voi
nella mia infanzia mi sono divertito a
coniare monete come semplicemente
prendendo dei tappi di bottiglia e
battendoli col martello e divertendomi
poi a farli diventare di fatto delle
monete che scambiavo con i miei compagni
di giochi così si giocava ai miei tempi
non c'erano
non c'erano i computer non c'erano
chiaramente non c'era internet non
c'erano i telefonini ci si divertiva
anche in questo modo coniando le monete
forse perché ciascuno di noi nel proprio
piccolo da piccolo desidera diventare
importante accumulando ricchezza
oggi la moda finanziaria e non solo dice
che bisogna comprare investire nei
bitcoin mio qua 1 questo è un b coin è
vero
o falso chi dice che è vero e falso
perché i bitcoin non sono non esistono
materialmente non sono delle monete e
tangibili questa è una riproduzione di
un bitcoin come sapete come come sapete
voi che mi state ascoltando i bitcoin
sono in realtà degli algoritmi che
vengono estratti
utilizzando dei computer dei grandi
computer o dei piccoli computer molto
potenti non è sempre stato così nei
secoli nei millenni oserei dire come
possiamo vedere si è passati dal baratto
pensiamo tema d'attualità oggi si era
ritornato di moda il
la battuta esci dalla grotta dopo un
lungo periodo di lock down che ci ha
visto non per volontà ma per necessità
per costrizione obbligati a stare in una
grotta che era la nostra casa davanti ad
un computer per partecipare alle lezioni
scolastiche che la famosa dad o per
lavorare lo smart working o
semplicemente perché non si poteva
andare altrove quindi facendo le
attività domestiche è ritornata di moda
questa espressione esci dalla grotta per
invitare le persone ad uscire dalla
propria abitazione recuperare quella
normalità e quella socialità che fa
parte dell'uomo
ma non è sempre stato così i nostri
antenati rimanevano nelle grotte per
scelta e per necessità perché ai tempi
c'erano molti più lupi di quelli che
sono ritornati anche le nostre nelle
nostre amate vallate c'erano gli orsi
c'erano animali feroci e soprattutto non
c'era una comunità soltanto a partire
dal sesto settimo secolo avanti cristo
si è cominciato a barattare cioè ad
introdurre con l'uscita dalla grotta
delle persone perché hanno cominciato a
fare comunità tra di loro si è
cominciata a nascere l'esigenza di
passare dall auto consumo e
dall'autoproduzione quindi mangio quello
che consumo utilizzo per vestirmi quello
che riesco ad utilizzare ammazzando la
capra la pecora e usando il relativo
mantello si è passati all epoca del
baratto
io produco qualcosa e lo scambio con
qualcun altro che moneta utilizzo in
quell'epoca non si utilizzavano delle
monete si chiamava baratto proprio per
perché era un modo di scambiare qualcosa
che io avevo prodotto con qualcos'altro
che aveva prodotto un altra persona con
la diffusione dei commerci si è poi
arrivati rapidamente all'introduzione di
forme di moneta quali prima sia parlato
di monete naturali o questo è un esempio
non spaventatevi non è un coniglio ma è
un è un pezzo di pelliccia di capra
perché perché ad un certo momento la
popolazione del mondo ha dovuto
individuare delle monete commerciali
riconosciute da tutti come aventi un
valore commerciale uguale per tutti in
cina le conchiglie
nella nostra europa ad esempio le
pellicce io che ho portato un pezzo di
pelliccia di capra ma avrei potuto
portare pellicce di altro tipo
si arriva poi si arriva poi finalmente
ad avere una una moneta più diciamo
effettivamente più fungibile perché più
fungibile cosa vuol dire più fungibile
una moneta che di perché non guardasse
al suo diciamo valore per tipologia di
capo di bestiame e via dicendo
commercializzato ma che avesse un valore
intrinseco e soprattutto uguale per
tutti
qual è la moneta stiamo parlando di
cos'è questo oro oro e argento quindi
con la diffusione dell'oro e
dell'argento come metodi per il
pagamento come monete non siamo ancora
arrivati alle monete legali non sono
ancora monete di fatto di natura diversa
quindi monete naturali estratte dalla
natura
la nostra è una zona ricca anche di
miniere come sapete soprattutto di oro
poi dismesse a causa di difficoltà varie
ma l'oro è stato per tanti anni il primo
e principale mezzo di scambio per
regolare i commerci era di fatto una
moneta si deve però aspettare ancora un
po per vedere le vere prime monete
quindi ho portato un esempio prima
arrivano le monete metalliche quindi
monete questo caso d'argento e
successivamente quindi badate che in
italia la prima moneta
legale ce l'abbiamo poco più di 250 anni
fa quindi non stiamo parlando di
millenni fa e poi arriviamo alla moneta
cartacea il dollaro
tutti quanti avrete preso una volta in
mano che per un certo numero di anni ha
rappresentato di fatto il la moneta di
riferimento perché per accordi di cui
forse avrete letto sui giornali o nei
vostri testi scolastici scolastici gli
accordi di bretton woods sono accordi
che prevedono sostanzialmente che siamo
un po avanti li vediamo adesso gli
accordi cosa prevedevano hanno previsto
nei primi anni del 1900 che gli stati
attribuissero alloro ad una determinata
quantità di oro una determinata quantità
di dollari come vedete un oncia di oro
che è pari a 31 grammi equivaleva per
convenzione tra tutti gli stati a 35
dollari usa
cosa significava significava che se io
presentavo 35 dollari alla banca
avevo la possibilità di avere in
conversione quella determinata quantità
di oro
questo cosa significava significava che
il denaro non poteva essere stampato in
modo illimitato perché doveva
corrispondere ad una determinata
quantità di moneta cartacea una
determinata quantità di oro che doveva
esistere esistere perché era estratto
dalle miniere lavorato e diventare
lingotti o sotto altra forma essere
conservato presso l'autorità centrale
quanto è durato questo sistema di
bretton wood non è durato tantissimo
perché perché gli stati soprattutto dopo
le due guerre mondiali che hanno falci
dato il nostro continente tra i 15 18 e
negli anni quaranta hanno costretto gli
stati a indebitarsi indebitarsi
attraverso l'emissione di nuove
banconote senza più riuscire di
conseguenza a assicurare la conversione
tra le banconote cartacee messe in
circolazione e l'oro si è arrivati
quindi alla fine del sistema di bretton
wood che nel particolare nel 1971 un
anno prima della mia nascita quindi ora
come voi visto e letto sui muri e sui
suoi libri non l'ho vissuto questo
sistema di bretton wood è stato messo
fine al sistema di bretton wood è
sostanzialmente con lui e le monete
circolanti non sono più agganciate ad
una loro convertibilità in oro
si arriva poi chiaramente ai giorni a
noi più vicini io come qualcuno in
questa stanza sicuramente abbiamo
vissuto l'epoca della nascita dell'euro
della moneta unica europea e credo molti
di noi forse tutti abbiamo soprattutto
visto la nascita dei big coin che in
realtà non sono nati sono un fenomeno
relativamente recente ma in realtà sono
nati ormai un po di anni fa la nascita
dei big coin viene riportata ad un uno
strano personaggio dalle origini ancora
incerte e
nasce con l'idea di disintermediare il
sistema bancario e finanziario creando
una moneta che andrà che dovrebbe andare
a sostituire nel tempo tutte le monete
attualmente presenti senza avere più un
autorità bancaria centrale ma di fatto
prevedendo che lo scambio avvenga
attraverso la rete internet
una vera e propria
cos'è questa una una catena perché una
catena perché è così importante questa
catena e perché chiaramente le
informazioni viaggiano questo attraverso
questa catena che metaforicamente
internet e ogni piccola informazione che
dovesse cambiare cambia l'algoritmo il
bitcoin e con lui altre cripto valute
che sono sono nate nel corso degli anni
nasce proprio con l'idea di essere
immodificabile e quindi sopperendo a
quello che è un problema che magari
anche voi è capitato mai capitato
raramente mai capitato di ritrovarmi in
mano delle monete false che però
evidentemente non c'erano delle monete
metalliche pazienza
hai perso 12 euro se erano banconote
cartacee da 20 o da 50 euro e evidente
che voi sapete che chi si ritrova una
moneta falsa in mano non deve rimetterla
in circolo sennò contribuisce anche sul
piano penale alla commissione di un
reato però può capitare con i bitcoin
con i bitcoin e le altre cripto valute
questo problema si dovrebbe
completamente annullare perché perché
sono monete immodificabile proprio per
effetto del fatto che sono create
attraverso degli algoritmi non
modificabili
qual è l'ulteriore evoluzione ed un
evoluzione che non abbiamo ancora
vissuto oggi i bitcoin sapete che è
altalenante ha dei valori che passano
che variano quotidianamente anche del 10
al 20 per cento può essere scambiato
attraverso i cosiddetti exchanger che
sono questi mercati delle cripto valute
chi di voi già avuto modo di acquistarne
sac è facilissimo acquistare dei bitcoin
dopo essersi registrati su questi
exchanger è sufficiente fare un click e
dopo pochi secondi viene acquistato il
bic o in lettere o le altre critto
valute per poi essere usate come
strumento di pagamento
ci sono dei siti internet che già oggi
consentono il pagamento utilizzando le
critto valute
oppure semplicemente essere conservato
per rimanere come un investimento che si
spera possa fruttare delle plusvalenze
dei guadagni nel corso del tempo
qual è l'ulteriore evoluzione i token
siamo partiti siamo tornati al titolo
del del ted token a chi cos'è un token
un token è materialmente un gettone e
qui ancora ricorda un po la mia memoria
ea quella di qualcuno di voi presente in
sala che può essere mio coetaneo questo
che ho in mano è un gettone un gettone
telefonico che ai nostri tempi veniva
utilizzato per andare nelle cabine
telefoniche perché non c'erano i
cellulari e avvisare papà e mamma che si
faceva tardi
questo era un gettone che in realtà poi
nel corso degli anni
ha avuto anche un valore commerciale
perché veniva utilizzato nei bar per
pagare il gelato o come resto se paga lì
un gelato è un esempio molto semplice di
quello che è un token il token è un
gettone che consente a chi ce l'ha in
mano di fare delle cose
cosa sono i token i talk che nascono con
l'idea di consentire a tutti coloro che
ne posseggono uno di poter utilizzare
quel gettone per regolare dei pagamenti
in catene di supermercati in soggetti
che possono essere amazon o altri
soggetti che operano nel settore dell'e
commerce e quello che viene sottoscritto
tramite token è lo smart contract
l'evoluzione ancora più recente dei
token e sono in non funge ball token che
conosce bene che conosce bene
sicuramente enrica borghi che ha parlato
prima di me perché sono la
digitalizzazione delle opere d'arte
quindi è un'evoluzione ulteriore dei
token pensata per consentire in
particolare di non rendere modificabile
e replicabile senonchè l'okay della un
dell'artista un'opera d'arte
questo è la nonna non funge volto che
quindi siate pronti al cambiamento
perché i cambiamenti
ne vedremo tanti nei prossimi mesi nei
prossimi anni
io non posso che augurarvi buona fortuna
e buon a vita
[Applauso]